so Dan recently revealed the gift that
you gave to him on the final day of
shooting this framed photograph my dad
actually gave me this little framed
photo on the last day of shooting our
show was a say on that it says Daniel it
was an honor being your partner son dad
EXO no I don't want to cry for you folks
but I just might it was actually a
photograph that was taken by our hair
stylist on the show Anya
Saurus she took this pic of the two of
us actually from from behind sitting in
our directors are our chairs Johnny Rose
and David Rose chairs and I happen to
have my hand on his shoulder as we were
watching something on the monitor I
thought it was an appropriate picture to
give him as a parting gift and I think
well and now I've got to get through
this without choking up but it was a I
think I said it was it was an honor
being your partner son boys it looks
like I won't be able to see that wedding
venue with you today your mother's had a
bit of a relapse you were side by side
with him all throughout this entire
process can you tell us about the
emotion that goes into that what it
feels like how proud you get to be at
your kids every day when you go to work
together well I I'm proud of so proud of
both my kids because they you know they
both came up in this show certainly
putting the show together with with
Daniel he proved himself almost right
out of the gate in terms of his writing
ability and then once we started the
show his his ability as that producer
just kind of you know blew me away this
is so almost something he was like born
to do not even talking about what he's
doing in front of the camera we started
in the beginning kind of together and I
always felt I had to mentor him in the
beginning as soon as I knew the best
thing you can do is just take a step
back and give him a little space and let
him do his thing
that was a lightbulb moment actually you
know for me it also gave me a bit more
free time which wasn't such a terrible
thing and Sarah you know as a young
actress came in and watching her in a
scene with Catherine O'Hara
you know still I was on set in front of
the camera acting in a scene with them
and at the same time thinking I can't
believe what I'm seeing here my
daughter's acting with Catherine and
then of course I've got the next line oh
hello hi I'm Twyla I'll be your waitress
today anyway
I read about you guys and everything
you've gone through some super crappy
super crappy so in the final three isn't
now what does the family go through and
Stephen sticks I mean without giving the
blueprint away too much when we see what
we expect everything resolves itself in
a just a lovely manner there may be one
or two surprises but I think it's gonna
be a very satisfying yeah
series ending season for the fans who
have been following the show that's for
sure
you